TIM KILBOURN: Hi,
I'm Tim Kilbourn,
from the Android framework team.
And I want to talk about
building great apps for Android
TV.
Android TV apps
are developed using
all the familiar
components and tools
from the Android framework.
So if you already have a
great phone or tablet app,
you're on your way to
bringing that experience
to the big screen.
However, there are
some key differences
between developing for a
phone or a tablet, and a TV.
In particular, the
information density on a TV
should be much lower than
on a phone or a tablet.
No one wants to read a
wall of text on a TV.
Also, the way we interact with
the TV is through a D-pad,
like a remote control or game
controller, rather than touch.
So make sure all of the
important elements of your app
are focus-able.
Let's look at an example of
an app written for Android TV.
This app uses minimal
amounts of text,
and everything is
reachable with the D-pad.
Navigating to find
something to watch
is easy with these layouts.
In fact, because
this browsing concept
is so common for a TV app, we've
built a new support library
to help you create
beautiful, easy
to use apps for the big screen.
By using the widgets and
fragments from this Leanback
Support Library, you will
be able to quickly create
apps that work well on TVs.
The Leanback Support Library
is based on the Model, View,
Presenter pattern.
We've made it
straightforward to separate
the way you display your
content from the model
objects you used
to store the data.
The model objects
come from your app.
We don't put any
requirements on them,
so it should be possible
to update an existing app
to run on a TV without
changing your model.
The Views are the
standard Android views
that you know and love, like
text views and image views
and so on.
What is new for Android in
this library is the Presenter.
Given a model
object, the Presenter
binds the data from
that object to a View
that the library code
can use to display
your items in all the
screens of your app.
In particular,
this same item can
be rendered in different ways,
in different parts of your app,
simply by replacing
the Presenter.
Let's look at some examples.
Here we have a screen
that lets the user browse
through the content catalog.
This is implemented
using a browse fragment
from the Leanback
Support Library.
The fragment is instantiated
and given an object adapter
that contains the model
objects and the Presenters
used to render them.
The library code in the
fragment takes care of the rest,
calling the methods
and the presenters
for each item to show
the views in the rows.
Next, we have a Detail screen.
The same model object
that was previously
rendered using a small
card view can now
be rendered to show
more details simply
by using a different Presenter.
We also see rows
of related content
below the Details
Overview, with Presenters
creating each of
those views as well.
In-apps search works
in the same way.
Your app will receive
the text of the query
as the user enters it,
and the search fragment
uses the object
adapter and Presenters
that you provide to
show the results.
There are a few
other things you'll
want to do to make your
app look great on a TV.
We've designed a
new Launcher that's
optimized for getting
you into the content
you want to see as
quickly as possible,
and that starts with
Content Recommendations.
Using the existing
Android notifications API,
your app can publish
recommendations
for videos or other content the
viewers will want to see next.
You specify the data, including
the card image in the text.
And the Launcher will show the
recommendations prominently
on the home screen.
The order of all
these recommendations
is determined by how the
user interacts with them.
So make sure you're creating
high-quality recommendations
that will make people want
to return to your app.
You can find more
details and sample code
for Presenters, Fragments,
and Content Recommendations,
on the new developer
site for Android TV.
Thanks for watching.
Now go make some great TV apps.